dans les années 70 certains marxiste
disait aux féministes
oui vous devez convergé vers le combat
ouvrier et des féministes se disaient
mais pourquoi est ce que les ouvriers ne
pourrait pas convergé vers le combat
féministe après tout il ya autant de
faim dans le pays que d'ouvriers sans
doute plus donc il n'y a pas de priorité
à faire l'ouvrier hommes il y
certainement exploiter
l'ouvrière femme l'est davantage et ce
n'est pas parce qu'on est ouvrier qu'on
peut pas être encore plus discriminée si
effectivement on est femme harcelée
sexuellement exploités économiquement
donc il ne faudrait pas faire une
hiérarchie en disant il ya le vrai
combat qui serait économique et les
autres combats qui serait non pas des
questions sociales mais des questions de
société je n'ai jamais compris
d'ailleurs la différence entre ces deux
concepts donc l'ouvrière qui est violée
par son patron est exploité par le même
patron je n'ai pas envie de dire qu'il
ya un vrai problème un faux problème
ce sont des questions massive et qui
sont finalement et quartier ou négliger
aussi bien par les partis traditionnels
que les nouveaux partis donc c'est pour
ça qu'il faut vraiment inclure tout le
monde est au fond et c'est là peut-être
qu'il y à véritable universalisme à
trouver peut-être même à créer la
question des discriminations qui est
aussi importante que la question
économique au sens marxiste du terme
elle est aussi universel car tout le
monde et discrimine abl par exemple la
question de l'âge
et bien tout le monde a été jeune tout
le monde est appelé à vieillir
et même quand on est entre deux âges par
exemple 30 ou 40 ans vous pouvez être
discriminés parce que vous êtes trop
vieux pour avoir une promotion alors
vous avez le talent ou jugés trop jeunes
paraît sur l'apparence et bien quelle
que soit votre apparence il ya des gens
qui vont trouver que vous avez une tête
qui ne leur vient pas au style
vestimentaire qui ne leur convient pas
etc etc
donc la question des discriminations
n'est pas la question des minorités
car on est toujours la minorité de
quelqu'un d'autre en fait et c'est pour
cela que c'est une question tout aussi
universel que la question économique
il ne faut donc pas les opposer il faut
au contraire dé réunir
oui
[Musique]